y'all were so quick to switch up y'all
wanted to cancel him and this woman says
yes because you believe the victim first
always
ready for the mind I'm ready believe the
victim
how do we know who the victim is
you're inherently participating in the
destruction of another person's life
you're actually attacking the victim
today's topic Rex Orange County okay if
you don't know Rex Orange County is he's
um some kind of singer or whatever
he's a musician his name is Rex Orange
County
but I just want to know what I'm talking
about that's correct okay I know I
thought that was a place in California
turns out it's an artist and people like
him
so man was being yo welcome to Logan
Quebec City what is that oh that's my
new one Monica long game Quebec what's
your name Dade County
that's weird Okay so uh homie was being
accused of um doing a lot of stuff to
underage people and as we thought they
had to cancel a portion of his tour was
dealing with that and then he put out a
statement today okay today all charge
the meat against me have been dropped
the crown prosecution Services reviewed
the evidence and decided that there's no
merit in this case going to trial not
guilty verdicts were entered to all the
charges I've always denied these and I'm
grateful that the independent evidence
has cleared me of any wrongdoing I have
never done anything to anyone I do not
condone violence I would like to clarify
some details around what I was accused
of as I have not been able to address
this until now inaccuracies about the
case have been circulated I was wrongly
accused of touching someone one evening
under leg Nick back
[ __ ] in her crack
hey bro this is not the time
I'm sorry man
I mean
don't act like you don't know what to
get against it
so
um I would like to clarify some details
uh six charges
okay accused of touching on their leg
Nick back and bottom that led to six
charges so for every time they got like
one charge
one size
that's one
you remove your hand
sorry
my apologies yeah you keep apologizing
for that [ __ ] but you in that [ __ ] what
you mean being very Hands-On your
[ __ ] hands on
you sound like you know what you look
like you know what you look like you
look at that [ __ ] movie with
Faison love and then prison was it Money
Talks
what happened
from a little hot man I was just
chilling man I was like a cop gonna come
and pull behind me he had lights and
everything how'd he grind me yeah man
no it was like grab him and it was
tripping they would try to they were
slinging like yeah like that yeah
[Music]
yeah that's how you control
and I think about like man in this we
just so comfortable
no because it's certain things though
like I won't turn your lower back it's
that there's certain things are
established you know what I mean though
it's it's established I need to when I
need to lead you I'm gonna lead you with
the hand on the back this and that
depending on what you're there's some
dances that you can even work I know you
hate that dance but I still dance it
right kizomba you're gonna leave with
your you're gonna you're gonna leave
with your with your hip with your hip
bone with your leg Yeah Yeah with your
shoulder where there's a lot of things
that you know I'm gonna be in a
motherfucker's box yeah pause but I'm
gonna be right yeah in in there so it
but it's it's established okay but then
there's some people you know the back is
very long and they
you know but in that kind of
circumstance even though I have all the
free reign to grab her here I might even
do something here on the back yeah she's
going under yeah right or I might just
remember here yeah return
there's never a time where I could push
her there's never a time where I could
play that's not allowed in that context
right no here between us you push me all
the time you believe like yeah but you
don't like this [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of here
I remember one time you pushed me so
hard I really felt like that kid
but we have the understanding convention
it all depends on what the [ __ ] you're
saying because sometimes you be saying
some stupid [ __ ] that matches the push
you understand what I'm saying so when
you finish doing that thing which you
knew exactly what the [ __ ] you was doing
I don't know that's so funny some [ __ ]
up [ __ ] it was so funny whatever exactly
but you yeah you know why I'm pushing
you you know exactly why I'm pushing you
understand that even though I understand
it one thing we never do
like 50. no I'm not 50. no
and some of them are violent no no the
way I flew I could have really hurt
myself that's cause you're a [ __ ] yeah
so [ __ ] get protected welcome to the
law okay
[Laughter]
hey go bad [ __ ]
you go to jail now
so go ahead
six star okay the only evidence against
me was the individual's account however
CCTV footage obtained by the police
contradicted their version of events
their partner was also present
throughout the entire company in
question and gave a statement to the
police which did not support the
allegations against me it's been a
difficult time for everyone involved and
I'd like to thank the people who've
helped me through it as well as my
family and loved ones for their
continued support okay so this you got
video footage that contradicts what they
said happen as well as their partner at
the time who also said way what you said
didn't happen okay
that's already a lot right there
this dude by all types of purposes a lot
of his fans had canceled him a lot of
his fans said we're not supporting you
anymore what the allegations came out
and what struck me is when I went to the
comment section of his family someone
says it's crazy to me how people are
saying [ __ ] like to switch up on some
people is going to be crazy like when
did it become wrong to change your
opinion on a situation as the facts were
brought to light yeah
the problem isn't that you change your
opinion the problems that you had an
opinion to begin with
if you don't know just say you don't
know
if someone makes allegation against
Peter I don't know Peter another person
unless they bring forth a bunch of
evidence to support it I'm like I don't
know
but if you just go well believe her he's
guilty oh wait he brought up evidence
well he's not guilty anymore that's a
backwards way of living life am I wrong
about that no that's what you say nobody
is switching up
personally as a woman
if uh if an application comes out
against one of my favorite artists no
matter how it is I'm going to believe
the victim until the artist is proven
innocent about how a lot of
[ __ ] function I want you guys
to appreciate it this is not innocent
until proven guilty this is guilty until
proven innocent that's how these people
are literally operating yeah but as a
court of
the court of people the court of the
people the court of public opinion
switch up is okay reminder to always
believe the victim until proven
otherwise
listen if you guys are like that and
you're my I hope you guys leave now if
that's how you really operate you just
believe anyone who says anything until
proven otherwise
I hope I lose you guys if I was this
dude I'd tell all these two random like
that and we're running on this kind of
Mantra I don't want you to ask me
personally that's uh ugh
but and maybe you don't feel that
strongly as I do I don't feel as strong
as you do I don't know me I find these
kind of comments the most disgusting I
feel like people don't want to walk this
hearth
without the feeling of not having an
opinion it feels like there's a lot of
people that they're like ah I have to
have an opinion on everything which is
something that's very impossible it's
impossible to have an opinion on
everything but you have to like
sometimes the hardest thing that I found
people to say was I don't know
what would you think about this I I
don't I don't know we have to have an
opinion on everything you don't have to
have an opinion on everything people
have to they they have to
viscerally have an opinion on everything
whenever it's brought up to them so
whenever they say an artist like that oh
they have to choose a side no you don't
listen to this one y'all were so quick
to switch up y'all wanted to cancel him
and this woman says yes because you
believe the victim first always
I'm like breath just take a step back
just take a step back you don't have to
call her a liar you don't have to say
you inherently believe me like I don't
know until more information comes to
light I'ma just keep it pushing because
it really don't change much for me and
let me tell you guys the only people who
do this whole believe her nonsense are
people who haven't had been faced with
an accusation
people who don't really want to accept
that there are people that [ __ ] lie
on a regular basis because it benefits
them because they didn't want to tell
their boyfriend they cheated on them
because the fact they just hated the guy
or they couldn't handle rejection well
or they got some mental instability I
don't know why there's a very vast
reasons why people lie but this idea
that when it comes to obligations all of
a sudden
all of a sudden you know what I'm saying
people want to do this whole thing where
like there's no way someone will lie
like yeah only three percent survive
allegations that are reporting that
aren't yeah it's only three percent are
reported
re-reported a bunch of them are not
reported even when you come with CCTV
even when you come with the boyfriend
saying like she lying that didn't happen
that way there's still people who are
not gonna believe so understanding that
like if you're watching this just drop
that whole Mantra that is a bad thing
and honestly it makes a lot of people
who are on the opposite end want to
refuse to believe anyone even when they
come with evidence because they've seen
so many people disingenuously believe
folks like Amber hurt yeah okay someone
said this someone says this
you ready for the mind [ __ ] I'm ready
believe the victim
how do we know who the victim is
believe the victim
you want to know what it really means
when they say believe the victim or
believe means just believe the woman
because women apparently don't lie it
inherently puts men in this position
where men are always a bad guy because
vast majority of the time I do not see
this kind of energy ever afforded to
supposed male victims noise it happens
in a blue moon but most of the time it's
not so this Paradigm is just another way
in which basically Society tells men
you're guilty of it irrespective of
whether we believe you or not and this
whole victim's like what if he's a
victim what if it's his life being
destroyed because some woman's a stalker
someone's upset you're inherently
participating in the destruction of
another person's life you're actually
attacking the victim
yeah ain't that [ __ ] up in your effort
to believe the victim you're actually
attacking the victim and you know what
from his perspective it's very easy to
become resentful if you lose a lot like
he didn't he's fortunate CCTV footage
from years ago not easy for everyone to
obtain not everyone has that luxury what
if it's true to just people in a room
her his words against hers if there is
CCTV and that life gets destroyed this
is what it ends well think about all the
time it does it you've participated
in hurting victims yeah but he's always
a safe man you don't know
if you're fine with hurting a bunch of
people to help a bunch of others
what does that say about you I'm curious
what does it say that you're being used
as some [ __ ] tool by some people to
do more evil I don't know it's just it
fascinates people think they're doing
this kind of virtuous thing I was like
no you're actually hurting people you
are hurting victims
so just think about that because when
you're on the receiving end
and it doesn't go your way and you got
to live with that [ __ ]
you become angry
resentful that's a bit crazy though yeah
why but let's just guess it's painful
it's really what you said it's like all
these [ __ ] are you really
nailed you never nailed me you hit it on
the head like cause
it's really [ __ ] that never
face that they don't know how traumatic
it is
to have someone say stuff like that or
people saying stuff like that about you
and then you have to defend it's already
[ __ ] up to prove something like that
to happen so you know how [ __ ] up it
is to prove something that did not
happen
true how hard that is now I'm here and I
gotta prove to [ __ ] that some
[ __ ] did not happen
I have to have evidence on things that
is not
but no you have to you know believe
women
because that's what it is how you say it
it really is that think about that girl
who ran around around here in our city
she's in a bunch of people and then she
got to use then all of a sudden she went
wait
and she did because I saw
she did yeah I met her comedy but
everybody but everybody was like but
everybody was like yeah believe her
believe her believe her but she was
doing the one doing the bad [ __ ]